hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in 1874 in hog
it's played between a Joseph Henry
Blackburn and the Henry William Burke
mark Gifford now this isn't the first
time I'm making a video on Joseph Henry
Blackburn who you all know what's called
the Black Death I will put a couple of
links to the description below where you
can check up on some of his other games
were I introduced him and said something
more about him and in my previous videos
I would often ask my audience why they
called him the Black Death and there
were always a lot of interesting answers
although I don't really think it's known
why he was called the Black Death it's
probably it is written somewhere in some
history books but since the last video I
did and mr. Joseph Henry Blackburn this
channel did grow a couple of hundred
thousand subscribers so maybe some of
our new friends could have a better idea
of why they called him the Black Death
but yeah in you know there are currently
a lot of draws happening in the world
chess championship and I thought as a
lot of you are disappointed would game
12 and the quick draw I just wanted to
mention that there is currently a
tournament being played between engines
in the chess comm engine championship
where they're playing all the games are
being placed from the position where
across and Curran agreed to a draw so I
will put a link to that in the
description below as well if you wanna
you know check that out but they're
getting back to this game yeah black
burns opponent is Henry bull in berkemer
Gifford and there is not a lot of
information available on him other than
that he was an English chess master and
that he was the first unofficial dutch
champion other than this game there are
a couple of more games available played
by him he competed in I believe it's
1878 Paris tournament which was won by
johannes tucker towards student of
adults Anderson and there I believe he
wants some 11th place whereas Joseph
Henry Blackburn won 2nd place so four
years from now they will also meet and
Blackburn will win both of their
encounters but this game it's really
crazy and well let's just dive straight
into it I'm sure you will enjoy it as
we've been facing so many supercomputer
for the past two weeks that I'm sure
this will come off as a refreshment and
as usual since I don't have a photo of
mr. Henry William Burke mark Gifford and
there is not all that much information
available on him I'm honoring the old
master by wearing a hoodie and also
there is a photo of the hoodie guy dear
so II for by Blackburn we have e5 Knight
to f3 Knight to c6 and now D for the
Scotch game we have each capture Sundy
four and now Bishop to c4 this is the
scourge gambit and white and the black
decides to go for Bishop to c5 this is a
well known line but there is just one
move I will I would like to mention
because there is a very very cool game
played by a Paul Morphy where more of
his opponent who's also a hoodie guy
played Bishop to b4 check and the Morphy
actually played this game without his
rook on a1 so with row cards and I'm
just gonna blitz out through it just so
you see what happens
c3 Morphy defense from check pawn
captures now Murphy castles we have
captures captures more fees threatening
the bush pawn here mr. Hudak guy goes
back defends the pawn and now e5 by
Murphy d6 we have rook to e1 pawn
captures and Knight captures and hoodie
guy captures the Queen Queen captures
and e1 and here more features finishes
the game in great style Bishop captures
on f7 would check King East 7 knife to
g6 check King captures on f7 and now
comes Knight captures on h8 and believe
it or not this is checkmate as the
bishop is controlling DF 6 squared the
knight is controlling the g6 Square and
the rook for me one is controlling all
of the squares on the e-file and the
black King has nowhere to go
the interface is still giving me some
issues here but yeah a very nice game
and I did a video on this game a long
time ago but yeah here in this game
Bishop to c5 instead of this Bishop to
b4 check Knights the g5 a similar idea
as in the two Knights defense where you
want to go hard against this f7 pawn but
the same idea defense wise does not
apply in the two knights defence black
will often go d5 but here you can simply
capture it and
now if ninety five then a white can
simply exchange everything captures
captures captures captures Queen h5
check g6 Queen captures here and white
will simply win a pawn and okay black
might get some nice development but all
in all white should be better so here
after Knight g5 we have Knight to h6
defending the f7 pawn this way Queen to
h5 would a triple attack against the f7
pawn and now Queen to e7 defending here
we have f4 and here you can see you can
notice that this game was played in some
1874 some 150 years before today and
today in modern chess you know that you
definitely want to push your deep on
make room for this Bishop and if this
was a modern game d5 would be played
after Bishop captures night before comes
up with an attack against the bishop
also you're threatening the c2 pawn so
something active would have been played
but as this is a very old game
we have castles here immediate and okay
it seems that black is not perfectly
safe there are no more attacks here
white castles as well and here we have D
6 D 3 would check isn't all that great
after king h1 captures and Knight c3
white will simply have improved the
position of asking and also the knight
will have been developed the knight is
now coming to d5 so nothing good is
happening here for black so black has
the right idea he wants to develop his
pieces as well we have d6 now comes f5
and excellent move by white threatening
the knight and h6 and also hindering the
development of the Bishop and c8 we have
d3 would check black now goes for this
but still the result is same white
simply improved that improves the
position of asking pawn captures and c2
and now Knight to c3 this Knight is now
definitely coming to d5 with Knight to
e5 going after the bishop on c4 and here
this is the well the the first critical
moment in the game here white can simply
win the game by force and I will give
you a moment to pause the video here and
try to find the winning idea for white
even though it was not played in the
game but it's it's interesting why it
wasn't played so I'll give you a couple
of seconds as you
for those of you who are able to do it
you are definitely not a romantic person
as this move was not played in the game
but you would have won the game and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
tonight captures on h7 wins the game by
force King captures and now f6 the queen
is under attack you will either lose the
Queen or you will capture the pawn and
then face Queen captures King g8 Knight
is now coming here after the Queen moves
well you can either go to d8 and then
give up the Queen or go here and then
face mate in one or on the other hand
after f6 you don't have to capture it
you can even move the Queen but then
comes F captures and g7 simply attacking
the rook after rook moves captures and
this will be checkmate so here you can
end the game immediately basically but
this was 1874 and in those days it
wasn't just about be you know beating
your opponent you also had to be cool
while while you did it
so here Joseph Henry Blackburn whom they
called the Black Death plays Knight to
d5 first he improves the position of his
Knight and brings another piece into the
attack we have Queen to d8 here and only
now does he play f6 and here we have a
very nice move by black here mister
Henry William Burke mark Gifford plays
Knight back to g6
and here he is preparing Bishop to g4
Bishop to g4 would be an excellent move
here because it would trap the White
Queen but mr. black death doesn't mind
he plays F captures and g7 now Bishop to
g4 doesn't work because with which this
pawn capture you also remove the
defender of the night on h6 so Queen
captures on h6 is also a threat but we
have King captures on g7 now black
simply and again prepares the Bishop to
g4 to trap the Queen but again we have a
position where so many moves win for
White Knight to have six points for
White Knight captures on h7 wins for
white but still this is 1874 and you
know you have to play the coolest move
and still beat your opponent so feel
free to pause the video here imagine
it's 1874 and you know just play a move
I'll give you a couple of seconds you
know just just the
with a shot for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations you now
definitely are a romantic person and for
those of you who just want injured show
the move Joseph Henry Blackburn played
is Queen captures on age six of course
and now you can either go somewhere like
g8 or h8 and face mate in one with Queen
captures on h7 or you can accept the
Queen sacrifice King captures an age six
was played and now of course comes nice
to e6 Czech delivering a discover chat
from the bishop on c1 and also the night
from e6 is covering the g7 square and
the g5 square so you can either go to h5
or you can prolong the suffering with
Knight to f4 as black also is playing in
the most romantic way possible
he decides to take his King for a walk
we have king to h5 Bishop to e2 check
taking the King deeper in we have King
to h4 and now again we have a very
exciting moment where White is actually
able to deliver meat into rook to a5
followed by rook to h5 is checkmate in
two and there's really nothing black can
do about it but it is not cool enough
for mr. black death so he goes rook to
f4 check decides to sacrifice even more
material to make his victory all the
more great with Knight captures on f4
now comes g3 the king is forced to come
to h3 King comes to h3 and now while you
can capture the knight on f4 which
either night he decides to do it with
this night night he captures on f4 and
this is now checkmate as the pawn is
preventing the King from escaping to h4
this Bishop is covering the lights worse
here and the King is of course covering
the g2 square so a beautiful checkmate a
very nice xx move game and I do hope it
was at least a little bit of a
refreshment for for this entire world
chess championship series that although
extremely exciting you know people
people do appreciate a shorter game now
and then so that's basically the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and although
there isn't a lot of information
available on Henry William Burke Mario
Gifford I was able to find this grave
it's a website that you know
follows where all the grades are and
there you can see on the bottom it says
Henry William Burke Mara Gifford and on
the bottom on the top is Ellie Eliza
Eliza was his wife so I believe the
website got it right it's located
somewhere in Greater London I will put a
link to the address in the description
below you know if you're somewhere
around Greater London maybe you would
like to pay the old Grandmaster a visit
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
bharatavarsa ravine Paul Hirst an
anonymous person of Brian meter and the
Maximillian Twitter for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and yeah do check out the useful
links in the description below there is
always something fun to see derp thank
you all and I will see you soon